[Music]
I'm not a morning person but when I get
up I get up I don't think you're like
that no you also hit snooze like 50
times in the morning I don't think
that's abnormal I love waking up when I
wake up but that's nice that's nice for
you but you don't understand how much it
annoys me just sleeping like a baby
she is a very deep sleeper most mornings
I have to like give her an edge or you
ever push the week around I'm not a
morning person I just have really vivid
dreams I hate waking up he's usually a
jerk about it hopefully this will get
her to wake up on her own without me
pushing her or hidden never to pull out
a get up we're gonna be trying different
alarm clocks they're supposed to help
you wake up I feel like you're going to
get very angry at some of these alarm
clocks
okay Mike we're trying this alarm clock
tonight it says to like fly away when
you use it it's gonna fly away yeah it's
just fly away
yeah we'll give it a shot you put this
little ball one like so and then this
goes on top of it like so very dangerous
hopefully like that Lissy will see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi wake up
Lucy what did you think of it I really
liked it oh you didn't like it okay
[Music]
today we're going testing out the
running nylon 5 you already know it I
used to have it yeah oh wow
did you roommate to help your room I
wake up no we're gonna test it out and
see if it'll help Mike get up I hope
this little [ __ ]
can roll really far away from him I hope
it makes him get out of it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
three big bailout fights living with her
okay tano agaves time so now we are
trying the journal armed Club they saw
we had a gun this thing pops up and you
ain't I had to target and that's when
the EVAs snoozes board turns off you
know I can't get up now why did it go
off again
I don't know I must be broken Mike got
so angry that he he took it apart I'm
surprised I thought he maybe would like
this clock because of like this video
game aspect of it but apparently he
hated it this much
so we tried all three alarm clocks the
rolling one the flying one and the gun
one and only one of them really worked
which was the flying one I was like the
most effective so like the fire one was
clean it was simple and it worked they
got it up and I didn't have to wake up
but then today I hated all three of them
Mike so what did you think of all the
clocks like they were all really
annoying and honestly not that effective
for the propeller or flying one boom
that one had the worst sound okay by far
but it seemed pretty easy for you to
shut off like mixed up the gun wanted
seemed to be the gun one I did not know
how to turn off right so I feel like
that made it better it was like infinite
snooze driving one yeah the one yes that
one was my favorite
it's like a little robot it's kind of
cute we have too many things stopping
and easy a nice open hardwood floor to
like go out and be free
and then you have to chase it I just
wish you would get up I'm hitting stop
hitting snooze
okay bye